son
énergie nous nous sommes
rassemblés parce que nous allons faire
de cette
élection une insurrection
civique qui va en se donnant d'abord
rendez-vous dans les
ur commencer ce
jourl la révolution cyenne qu'il est
nécessaire
d'accomplir pour changer en profondeur
la vie du peuple qui pti et ouvrir la
brèche qu'attend toute l'Europe de son
volcan français
oui ça se voit ça se sent ça se
sait le printemps temps et pour dans 3
jours et chaque matin qui se
lève la lumière estend son domaine dans
la
journée la nuit se
replie Vienne le temps des cerises et
des jours
heureux tel est notre premier message
ici pour tous ceux qui nous entendent et
nous écoutent
sur cette place dans les Ruges
adjacentes d'où l'on ne peut
avancer et dans chaque foyer où l'on
nous
regarde ici en France métropolitaine et
outrem et partout en Europe et partout
où l'on parle français où l' rêve
français parce qu'on attend de lui ce
grand
mouvement qui ne libérera pas seulement
ce que nous sommes mais partout il y a
des
servitudes nous adressons notre salut
fraternel et notre
solidarité au peuple grec qui
pti aux Espagnols au Portugais aux
Italiens à tous ceux qui ont pour
l'instant sur leur
tête le poids de
l'oppression venu de l'abject
Troïa qui a décidé
d'orénavant de contrôler chaque peuple
et à qui paraîil il faudrait demander
l'autorisation de disposer librement de
nous ici sur cette place nous faisons le
que si c'est nous qui sommes appelés à
reconstruire la règle du jeu de notre
pays en convoquant la constituante qui
est
nécessaire
alors plus jamais une seule délégation
de
souveraineté du peuple ne sera jamais
opéré sans qu'il ait été auparavant
consulté par voie de
référendum la souveraineté du peuple
telle est la grande question qui
dorénavant va occuper toute
l'Europe qui se voit une nouvelle fois
engagé dans une entreprise qui commet la
même erreur qu'au précédentes saisons de
l'histoire c'est on l'a construit sans
les peuples et sans la
démocratie alors pour commencer cet
immense
chantier d'abord chez nous en
France nous sommes venus au bon endroit
à la bonne
date le bon endroit
ici où a été juré une première fois le
serment de se rassembler pour empêcher
tous les moyens dont nous disposons les
fascistes de s'emparer de la
patrie cette
place où a été en
1935 rassembler cette manifestation
féministe qui déjà voulait briser les
chaînes du patriarcat en demandant que
le suffrage soit réellement
universel
cette place où a été brûlé le dernier
trône des
rois cette place où tout commence
toujours et qui est le point de départ
de toutes nos révolutions et d'abord de
la
première celle qui se fit en
1789 en abattant la citadelle des
tyrans
celle qui se fit avec des mots et des
principes si grands qu'il rendait
possible ce fait que
depuis il est possible d'être français
ou que l'on soit dans le monde et ici
même en France que ses parents l' été ou
non du moment qu'on s'accorde pour dire
et reconnaître comme égal quiconque
comme nous dit liberté égalité
fraterné nous sommes à la bonne
date le 18 mars commencement de la
grande et glorieuse Commune de
Paris voici parmi nous l'ombre d'une
femme Louise Michel à qui nous nous
dédions
voici que nous répondons à notre
tour à l'appel de Jules valess et du Cri
du peuple qui concluait l'appel à la
première insurrection par ces mots place
au peuple place à la commune et nous ne
disons rien d'autre encore
aujourd'hui à la bonne date
50 ans après la fin des combats en
Algérie je déclare au nom du peuple ici
rassemblé
oui la guerre est finie et nous ne
permettrons pas qu'on la recommence
ici nous sommes une même famille peuple
du Maghreb peuples des nations arabes
berbè et nous peuple
français après le silence des armes nous
devons à nos enfants la paix des
cœurs peuple français M dites à cette
occasion la terrible leçon de ton
histoire là où n'a plus court l'égalité
humaine là où n'a plus court la liberté
totale des consciences et des droits
politiques là où n'a pas court la
fraternité alors la France n'est plus
possible c'est
pourquoi il nous faut aujourd'hui dans
cette France défigurée par les
inégalité
sociale
territoriale culturelle
entre femmes et
hommes tournerz la page une nouvelle
fois de l'ancien régime
commencer un nouveau
chapitre qui
permettra comme c'est notre tradition
divers que nous
sommes en refondant la
République de refonder la France
elle-même et en refondant tous ensemble
la République de nous
reconstituer comme un peuple unique
libre fraternel
et nous
commencerons par où il faut
commencer c'est-à-dire qu'en convoquant
cette
constituante nous
commencerons la première de toutes les
égalités qu'il est ind dispensable de
constituer la
parité
devra être strictement
paritaire et ainsi
commencera la marche de l'égalité
l'égalité par quoi tout commence en
France
l'égalité qui nous conduira à
proclamer la fin des privilèges du
capital
l'établement
en
entreprise
corrigeant ceux qui n'avaient pas été
achev
quand comme l'a dit Jean jores la grande
révolution a rendu les Français rois
dans la cité et les a laissé CF dans
l'entreprise ces droits nouveaux des
travailleurs droit de
vetau le droit de préemption sur la
propriété du capital à la portée des
travailleurs qui se constitueraiit en
coopérative
ouvrière le droit de réquisition par la
patrie lorsqu'un bien est réputé
commun c'est nous qui
inscrirons ce droit nouveau qu'il y a
une propriété collective humaine des
bien de base tels que l'eau et
l'énergie c'est nous qui donnerons toute
sa place à la dignité de l'amour humain
en étendant à tous les couples les
droits qui s'attachent aujourd'hui aux
couples
hétérosexuel liberté liberté
c'est elle que nous voulons faire
cheminer par la route de
l'égalité
liberté il faut que les droits
fondamentaux de la personne humaine
entre dans cette constitution et le
premier d'entre tous le droit de
disposer de soi sans entrave aucune
c'est nous qui mettons pour que plus
personne ne soit tenté d'y tou
quand les menaces s'accumulent comme
nous le voyons en ce moment c'est nous
qui mettons dans notre Constitution le
droit à l'avortement qui reconnaî à
chacune le droit de disposer d'ellemême
son corp ntant la propriété de
personne c'est nous qui mettrons dans
notre
Constitution le droit de décider de sa
propre fin et d'être assisté lorsqu'on
en
décide c'est
nous qui installeront et
confirmeront la liberté de conscience la
plus absolu et qui pour cela
décideront que la laïcité déjà inscrite
dans la
Constitution sera étendu sans aucune
exception à à tous les territoires de la
République c'est-à-dire que le Concordat
sera
abrogé et le bénéfice de la loi de 1905
étendu à toutes les terr
française la Polynésie la Guyane
Alice et Futuna la Nouvelle Calédonie
aussi bien qu'en Alsace et en
Moselle
c'est nous qui étendrons les territoires
de la liberté là où l'inventivité
humaine et son génie a créé de nouveaux
espaces c'est nous qui dirons que la
liberté sur la toile est inaliénable et
qu'il ne sera plus jamais permis de
faire
ADOPI c'est
nous qui
interdirons fondant en cela un principe
nouveau qui interdiront une fois et pour
toujours que le vivant soit
breveté et qu'il y ait une propriété
privée de l'existence
elle-même c'est
nous qui libérerons une bonne foi la
en faisant en sorte que son indépendance
dorénavant ne soit plus garanti par un
homme surtout après avoir vu quel usage
il avait été fait de cette garantie dans
le
passé
dorénavant nous placerons
l'indépendance de la
justice sous la protection et
l'attention du Parlement
lui-même France
d'égalité de
liberté tu te dois d'être la patrie de
la fraternité et des devoirs humains
totalement
accomplis nous dans notre
Constitution nous regarderons tous les
enfants qui nous sont donné d'un même
œil en France
d'orénavant né sur la terre de France
français droit du sol
intégral tel est le premier devoir de
fraternité
humaine et en voici un autre nouveau
qu'il s'agit
d'assumer nous sommes nous cor
responsable de l'écosystème dans lequel
vivent tous les êtres humains et sans
lequel pas un seul d'entre eux ne peut
vivre ni mener quelque Corelle politique
que ce
soit c'est
pourquoi nous accomplirons notre devoir
à l'égard de l'humanité
universelle nous proclamerons que les
Français s'astreignent par leur
à
s'acquitter de leur devoirs en éteignant
la dette
écologique et que plutôt que leur
fichure règle d'or qui ne concerne que
leur portefeuille nous appliquer la
règle verte qui protège la
planète
ou
commence une
insurrection le peuple qui s'était
dissou dans
l'abstention dans le refus
deobtempérer aux injonctions des petits
je sais
tout au mauvais qui leur donneent des
conseils et qui quand c'est leur honneur
et leur devoir de porter leurs parolle
quand les Français disent non s'en vont
ensuite dire que nous aurions dit
oui ceux qui nous ont
trahi notre premier
devoir pour commencer notre chemin et de
nous en
débarrasser telle est la première tâche
que doit accomplir notre
insurrection si elle veut pouvoir
ensuite se donner le grand rendez-vous
de la révolution
citoyenne
Machado le poète a
dit que le chemin se fait en
marchant cette marche nous l'avons
commencé depuis la
nation et nous nous sommes retrouvés ici
à Bastille
pour une
étape dont nous continuerons la
trajectoire
bientôt de la Bastille des
révolutions jusqu'à la place de la 6e
République nous sommes le cri du
peuple des ouvrières et des ouvriers
précarisés méprisés humiliés abandonnés
nous sommes le cri du peuple celui de la
femme qui met au monde un enfant dans un
camp de
rétention nous sommes le cri du peuple
celui de l'enfant qui n'a pas de toit et
qui n'a pas d'instituteur quand il va à
l'école nous sommes le cri du peuple de
tous ceux qui prêt à apporter le
concours de leur intelligence de leur
créativité qui parfois amenant vie
refuse d'appliquer la morale de
l'égoïsme qui dit profite et
tistoi je vous
appelle à commencé ce printemps des
peuples
ouvrez en France par vos bulletins de
vote la brèche par laquelle ensuite
passera le vote des Grecs puis en
octobre prochain celui de nos camarades
allemands qui souffr des merveilles du
prétendu modèle
libéral voici le
printemps faites votre devoir en
accourant à la
rescousse partout les Lutes ouvrières
vous
appellent
faites votre devoir en vous découvrant
les uns les
autres mettez à la mode la couleur
rouge prenez les places et les rues de
la République comme vous le pouvez dans
chaque ville et chaque village de
France et vous
autres à
Toulouse sur le
capitle à Marseille au
Prade
organiser la réplique du 18 mars à la
Bastille
assemblez-vous par
milliers vous
souvenant de l'appel sacré que vous a
adressé ceux qui vous ont précédé dans
cette
lutte inscrivant dans la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyens de
1793 quand le gouvernement viole les
droit du peuple
l'insurrection est pour le peuple et
pour chaque portion du peuple le plus
sacré des devoirs et le plus
indispensable des devoirs
vive l'humanité
universelle vive la France vive
République vive la
sociale les de
la
les
c'estéruption de la fin qui ass que son
le ras sous lesesclave debout
debout le mondee va changer de bas nous
ne sommes rien
soyonsnous c'est la
lutte
finale N pourous et
demain la TER inter
nationale sera le genre
humain c'est la
l
finale nous pour nous et
demain la TER
nationale sera le genambre
humain de la
de
to
arrivé contre lous de la
tyranie les T son BL
r les T son BL
Rous les compag
J
March
marchons bravo et
maintenant un ch de
constance Jean-Luc Mélenchon s'est donc
exprimé place de la bastile à l'issue de
la grande marche pour la 6e république
réunissant des milliers de personnes le
candidat du Front de gauche qui ne cesse
de grimper dans les sondages
franchissant la barre des 10 % très
bonne soirée à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires